[موسيقى]
تحديات سياسيه منافسات اقتصاديه ها هي
امريكا تسلك مجددا طريقه جارنا القمر
التمس واحد اسمه البرنامج الذي وضعته ناسا
اجزاؤه ثلاثه تنتهي عام 2025 ولكن هذه
المره لا تعود الولايات المتحده وحيده الى
القمر بل ما عدد من الدول مثل السعوديه
والامارات والبحرين التكلفه 100 مليار
دولار
فيديو فيديو
العلميه قوت وضع الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها واظهرت الحلفه مركزا للتقدم
العلمي لا يمكن اقصائه خاصه بظل السباق
نحو الفضاء الذي اعلنت عنه كل من الصين
وروسيا اما الجانب الاقتصادي فهو السبب
الاخر لسباق الولايات المتحده الى القمر
الهيليوم من القمر تحوي الارض من هذه
الماده على عده كيلوجرامات فقط اما تربه
القمر فيعتقد انها تحتوي على ما يقدر
بمليون طن منها بسبب التفاعل المباشر مع
اشعه الشمس عبر ملايين السنين وان يساعد
الهيليوم في تطوير الصور اكثر امنا وارخص
بفارق واسع من التفاعلات النوويه ثم توفير
قدرا هائل من الطاقه انايا حسنا اهتمام
الولايات المتحده بالقمر ليس محصورا بحرف
موارده الطبيعيه فقط الامر اعمق من ذلك
بكثير بل يتعده الى المصلحه العسكريه خاصه
مع تاسيس قوه الفضاء الامريكيه قبل
السنوات بدات تتضح رؤيه مهمه هذه الكتيبه
من الجيش الامريكي مع حديثي الجيشين
الامريكي والصيني عن اجراء عمليه عسكريه
خارج مدار الارض للسنوات
[موسيقى]
التي تتمكن اولا من السيطره على كم من
هائل من الموارد الفضائيه سوف تمتلك اقوى
اقتصاد في العالم بلا شك ولكن تبقى
القوانين التي ستنظم وجود كل هذه الدول
وسباقها غامضه ما عدم تحديد معاهده الفضاء
الخارجي عام
1967 تفاصيل وقوانين العمل في الفضاء وكل
ما ذكرته انذاك اعتبار القمري والمجرات
السماويه الاخرى متاحه للاستكشافي
والاستخدام
يا صباح العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن